JASON SILVA: It is
said that consciousness
is mediated by chemistry.
Our moods are dances
of chemistry occurring
in our brains and bodies.
And we can mediate
this chemistry,
this psychopharmacology,
through the ingestion of drugs,
but also through
the participation
in certain activities
through placing the body-mind
in certain spaces and places.
A beautiful cathedral,
a beautiful museum,
a beautiful building
or structure
can architect a particular
flavor of consciousness.
In fact, even the placebo effect
is not really an illusion.
Because real chemistry is
happening in our brains
when we believe that
what we're taking
is going to affect how we think.
And so our moods are mediated
by mind, by world, by chemistry.
And it makes you wonder
if the words of David
Pearce, the philosopher
who wrote "The Hedonistic
Imperative," should, perhaps, be
taken a little more seriously.
He talks about designing
new mind-ware for ourselves.
He talks about designer drugs
that will allow us to program
gradients of consciousness that
take us to spaces and places
in blissful mind-body states
that we cannot even fathom.
I mean, he basically says we
can become paradise engineers.
And that it is our
moral responsibility
to create these prescriptions
of mind for ourselves,
to basically deconstruct
and engineer nirvana,
to create virtual realities that
we can inhabit and believe in
and suspend disbelief within.
And accept new
software for the mind.
Upgrade.
The post-human gets to
inhabit spaces of subjectivity
that will make the old world
seem barbaric by comparison.
I think it is our responsibility
as the meaning makers,
as the dreamers of dreams,
to turn all of interior life
into a poem, a living, dynamic,
living, breathing work of art.
You see festivals like Burning
Man, these gatherings that
bring in hundreds of
thousands of people
to try to turn the world, to
turn the stage in which we
dwell into something more
beautiful-- something
with a little more
compassion, a little more
empathy, a little more
grace, gratitude, and bliss--
to decenter the
ego, to transcend
Maslow's hierarchy
of needs, and to go
somewhere deeper and higher.
Is this possible for ourselves?
There's experiments.
We've seen people try
to do it-- creating
these heterotopias, these
temporary spaces in which it
seems like it's possible.
But then you watch
the news, the doom
and gloom, the
terrorist threats,
and you get a little
bit depressed.
It makes me think that the
goal, that the mission,
that the end game
might not be possible
because there's too many
people conspiring against it.
But I remain steadfast
that we can't give up.
Beauty will win.
Love will win.
Aesthetic arrest,
transformation, illumination,
grace-- these are
the things that
are worth fighting
for and working for.
Yeah, I get depressed
sometimes when I watch TV.
But then I want to
go make more videos
and put more beauty out into
the world and induce goosebumps.
Rhapsody and rapture for all.
That's what I want.